we are back with the one and only
marishka hargitay
okay so you are the longest running
female character in television history
crazy it's crazy
crazy
i have chills everywhere when i say that
how does that function and feel inside
i feel um
very
uh satisfied stated
because i'm having i think more fun now
than i ever have so
i feel uh grateful i love i love my cast
like i i love them they're like family
now and i'm also mostly grateful but
that the show that's the longest running
show on television
is
is about
believing victims and um so that that
for me is the most rewarding thing and
today i'll share as i was leaving my
house this young girl came by and she
went
and uh
she said marishka i said yes she said
and and and the way the poise that she
had she said i probably am your biggest
fan you changed my life and i'm going to
become a psychologist for victims of
sexual assault and domestic violence and
for me i just went
okay okay my my day's made my hair's
made it's it's that yeah so it's very
it's a gift i i feel like i have the
best job and um
deeply fulfilled and sort of can't
believe it all at the same time what is
the secret to that
i love i love the character and i love
what she represents and because the
show's been on so long we get to work
with these amazing actors that
sometimes i just pinch myself and i go
wait how did i get here you mean like
when you saw your husband and he was a
guest star in svu and you thought what
who is that clark gables superman guy
that i need to marry today i mean he is
when your husband walks in any room
he is the tallest most handsome
lovely
he has this
larger than life energy around him
what was your first encounter with him
like was it love at first sight was
there a spark what because he's a real
presence he is and i was nervous
and i heard he was german
and i didn't know what to do
and so i said so oh this is so
embarrassing
i said so you're a crowd
it goes like this that's funny
then i went
oh my god and then chris maloney's like
but that's sort of like that german
sense of humor yes that's right
and then after it was he he's so funny
and so different than anyone i've i've
ever met and we had such a sort of
beautiful um
getting to know each other and learning
how to
see each other and beautiful courtship
and here we are you know 17 years
married 19 years in
and you know still learning about each
other every day but like on that first
day okay are you like because you know
you're at work also i on the first day i
was so so nervous and i felt very he was
very handsome and it was uh distracting
and then he would come back the other
days and the all the producers would
look at me and go
and give me like eyes and stuff did they
know could they tell yeah
i'd never been like that to anyone
to anyone ever
and it was funny because my friend you
know i was single i was 35 and my
friends are like marishka you need to
get out more nobody's going to just show
up on your show and ask you to marry
[Laughter]
and i was like oh yeah
you would have asked me to marry you
thank you
thank you
i swear i do believe it was great karma
and this is do you know do you know
where our first date was uh no tell me
please
it's a little too good to be true
our first date he asked me to go to
church with him
yeah
and i was moving and i said peter i i
would love to but not today i'm moving
today and he goes oh come on it's an
hour it's an hour and it was so funny
and i just couldn't resist so i went to
church and it was that day i remember we
went to church and i had this little
daisy flower necklace and this it was um
june 2nd
and i'm crying and he thinks that i'm so
moved by the sermon right and i'm crying
because i'm like i know i'm going to
marry him
i found my husband i love him
and you deserve it
that's why i think we all root for you
so much is because we can all tell we
love you because you are a phenomenal
human being
and you deserve this thank you thank you
thank you
thank you to the gods and karma and
goodness because we need to know
that that happened you had from jeremy
irons and carol burnett bradley cooper
bob saget
wait who i might
oh
so sad
bob saget what a
gem and uh unicorn of a man but my god i
think he might be the funniest person i
ever met he was so
funny and naughty too when i hung out
with him so naughty and would shock me
and i it was one of those things where i
go you can't shock me oh you just said
that out loud it was so crazy but so but
also i guess it was always okay because
he was so generous of spirit and so kind
and loved his family and loved his
friends he was like a lover and he
wanted to have fun he uh
he was uh so special yeah yeah i i i you
can tell when
the way that somebody affected the world
and i wish people know it while they are
here and present and able to feel that
love i'm going to tell you what i'm
thinking right now i'm dying to know
i'm just i just had this moment of you
know i have flirted
with
doing a talk show my whole life
and i just realized i'm sitting on
a talk show of what
what mine would have been and it's here
with you because you're giving out the
love and so i'm so grateful for that
because it's here
you're sure
oh i mean it i really mean that
this is what it does
really
love joe
this is a fun one i don't want to leave
[Music]